hola a todos para mí es un honor estar
aquí el día de hoy porque les voy a
compartir una de mis mayores pasiones
que es el arte quiero que vean muy
atentamente la fotografía de la obra de
arte que está en la pantalla porque más
adelante les voy a preguntar que ven en
la obra gracias al arte yo encontré la
definición de una de las grandes
preguntas que me hacían alrededor del
mundo que es emprender que es innovar
una pregunta que no le encontraba una
respuesta ahora a lo largo esta
presentación les voy a compartir otras
dos lecciones que aprendí en el mundo
del arte y por último les voy a decir la
razón por la que siempre traigo zapatos
rojos una cosa por la que todos me
conocen el mundo ahora bien yo cuando
era pequeño era una persona bastante
normal tenía metas sumamente
conservadoras tengo una familia
tradicional y recuerdo que primero que
nada no usaba zapatos rojos era anti
social me daba pena hablar a las niñas y
recuerdo que cuando era pequeño me fui
emocionando por el mundo de las ciencias
y me llevo a tal nivel en donde llegué a
ese punto en donde logré consolidarme
dentro de una carrera científica estaba
desarrollando nuevas tecnologías corrí a
toda velocidad de esta carrera
obviamente me volvió un poquito más
antisocial
pero en ese punto de mi vida recuerdo
que yo aspiraba algún día a inventar
algo que me llevara obtener un premio
nobel pero en lugar de eso mi carrera
científica se vuelve una carrera
empresarial creo mi primera empresa por
medio del desarrollo de la tecnología
para producir con biocombustibles en
méxico y en el mundo entero de una
manera más rentable y esta tecnología me
lleva a expandir más mercados nacionales
internacionales y llega un punto en
donde si me buscas en google salidad que
yo era el rey del biodiésel y en ese
proceso y consolidarme como empresario
recuerdo que a mis 18 años salió ese
primer artículo de fueros que decía cómo
hacer un millón de dólares antes de
graduarse con mi fotografía y cuando yo
era pequeño la mayoría las personas
aspiran a generar grandes capitales para
comprarse un avión una casa el carro de
sus sueños yo todo mi dinero me lo gasta
en arte que era una de mis mayores
pasiones pero como todos no tenemos una
historia fácil a mis 18 años se me
ocurre irme a hacer una empresa
sumamente diferente a un país bastante
lejano del mío que es méxico y me voy a
suiza hacer una empresa de participación
ciudadana
y en aquel momento me olvidé de todo no
olvide de comer de hacer ejercicio
me sentí inmortal no dormía y primero la
empresa entre crisis la empresa tenía un
problema de flujos después me hablan de
la escuela y me dice anda bien te vamos
a expulsar llevas más de 17 materias
reprobadas por faltas donde has estado
yo perdón se olvidará clases como ocho
meses
ese año tome más de 300 vuelos en 365
días y eventualmente la vida te lo cobra
me enferme tuve que regresar a mexico a
reestructurar las empresas y todos me
decían daniel y es tu fin yo me sentía
con él pacquiao relleno que hago pero
cuando tú crees que las cosas están mal
siempre pueden ir peor y en aquel
momento y algo de lo que nadie habla es
de donde con la familia para mí la
familia siempre ha sido lo más
importante mi padre mi madre un día se
sienta nacional conmigo y con mi hermano
y cuando menos lo imaginamos nos dicen
esta es la última cena en familia nos
vamos a divorciar que es el divorcio mis
padres nunca nos enseñaron eso en casa
en la escuela nunca seco tocó el tema el
divorcio era un tabú y yo me peleé con
mi papá y con mi hermano
donde se fueron a vivir yo dije yo me
voy a quedar con mi mamá una hermosa my
casa que nunca ha trabajado dije mamá
luchona y colusión olvide un pequeño
detalle mi mamá y yo peleamos por todo
siete días después me corrió de la casa
yo no sabía quiénes eran mis verdaderos
amigos en aquel momento todo está
enfocado en la empresa en mis proyectos
profesionales y durante más de dos meses
vivía en mi carro no sabía quién hacer
yo no era para que ahorre siendo que
aducen ahora para que recién no quedó
con ese huevo y que no me encima
y todos nuevamente me decían daniel ya
es tu fin y en aquel momento de la vida
recuerdo que me di cuenta que tenía que
dedicarle más tiempo a mi persona tuve
la oportunidad de irme a meditar hasta
la india y en la india conocí a una gran
maestra que me dijo àngel todo este
lamento
imagínate que eres como una flecha en un
arco entre más atrás te hagan más lejos
vas a llegar y tenía toda la razón temía
que para cambiar el mundo a mi país a la
gente a mi alrededor tenía que cambiar
como persona lo primero que tuve que
hacer fue independizarme sanear la
relación con mis padres sanear mi tema
educativo tenía que graduarme a la
universidad y posteriormente
reestructurar todas las empresas y en
ese proceso me tocó empezar a compartir
mi historia al día de hoy ha dado más de
500 conferencias por todo el mundo desde
la universidad de harvard hasta la
universidad de pekín universidades
públicas y privadas de todos los lugares
que se pueden imaginar y siempre me
hacía la misma pregunta
danielle que es emprender que es innovar
cuál es la receta cuál es la fórmula tú
qué has emprendido en tantos sectores y
en una pregunta que nunca contestaba
y fue por medio de mis mayores pasiones
que es el arte que encontré la respuesta
un día yo iba caminando por las calles y
estaba en un estado del sur de méxico
que se llama oaxaca y veo a ese hombre
haciendo un cuadro con hilo sobre un
pedazo de seda una aguja curva y mete a
los hilos una y otra vez y yo dije oye
está más de 50 países está en un montón
de museos pero nunca ha visto esa
técnica particular y le dije oye maestro
en cuanto a mera vendes mi seno las
vendo la regaló yo como que las rehalas
dónde vives qué comes y me dice se me
olvida comer y vivo en la calle yo dije
estos mexicanos inmortales
e insistiendo me la quiso vender en la
noche me entero que él vivía del trueque
ropa por un cuadro comida por un cuadro
al siguiente día lo busqué durante horas
lo encontré elige maestro un trueque lo
que tú quieras por ese cuadro mis hay
que tener poderes está bien y en aquel
momento me imaginé que me iba a ver
cualquier cosa menos lo que me pidió un
curso de encuadernación en la escuela el
maestro francisco toledo francisco
toledo es como hablar del maestro botero
uno de los grandes artistas mexicanos y
recuerdo que inmediatamente corrí para
que el curso regrese y le dije aquí está
tu beca ya no podía al cual y me dice no
no está listo le falta una semana y oye
pero yo mañana me ve a monterrey está
dos horas en avión como me lo vas a
mandar foto déjame dinero yo te lo mando
en una semana
lg dinero regrese a mi casa le conté
esta historia a mis amigos a mis padres
a la semana todos oyen y el griego el
cuadro lo nombra
dos semanas y un mes ya llegó no
llegaría le marcaste y yo no pues si no
tiene celular ni zapatos imagínense y mi
mamá que es un genio para esparcir
rumores seguramente sus mamás son
similares
a todos mis amigos les decía mi hijo que
dicen que es un muy buen empresario
científico a que no saben celoso lyon
guasa que ni a la calle
galicia mano antes diciendo eso me ama
este jodió y cuando tu mamá dice algo
mejor no le hagas el problema luego por
eso te corren de la casa preso es otra
historia
cuatro meses me estuvieron peleando con
el maestro de la calle que me había
robado mi dinero era un jueves cuatro
meses después cuando menos lo esperaba
por la tarde llegó una de las obras más
maravillosas que había visto en mi vida
a mi casa una obra con kilómetros y
kilómetros de hilo sobre un pedazo de
seda y ni una gota de pintura un impulso
a los pocos días me llevó a volar esa
ciudad y a buscarlo por todos lados
hasta que lo encontré le di las gracias
y le dije maestro quiero preguntarte una
sola cosa cuál es tu sueño más grande la
vida y me contestó que mi obra sea
conocida en el mundo y me si tu sueño
cuál es y le dije mira en el mundo del
arte
yo quería coleccionar pero después de
conocerte ha cambiado y que yo quiero
ser amigo a los grandes artistas de mi
época de mi generación antes de que sean
famosos y sin un interés económico
apoyarlos y me dice qué propones elige
mira de entrar yo creo que tú eres uno
de los grandes y ante mi locura e
impulsividad que siempre ha sido así
saqué mi cartera y le dije mira aquí
está una tarjeta de crédito las llaves
de mi departamento te propongo que te
vengas a vivir conmigo a monterrey
dije pues ya vivo solo porque no optaron
hombres no
llego a mi casa y le pregunté voy a
maestro y esa técnica donde la
desarrollaste no hace como 15 años
cuando estuve en la cárcel de manera
injusta pero estuve como en todos unos 2
añitos en la cárcel haciendo pelotas de
fútbol con hilo me di cuenta que yo
podía entrenar lo que fuera iba
estuviste en la cárcel
todo lo discriminaban me decían daniel
ten cuidado en las noches cierra tu
puerta con llave y les decía a ver si
hay algo que yo no tolera es la
discriminación traten lo como si fuera
mi hermano y en aquel momento en mi vida
perdí a muchos amigos por ese tema en lo
particular nadie cree en nosotros todos
decían están locos yo decía en mi tiempo
libre yo lo voy a promover con grandes
empresarios políticos mieres del mundo
voy a ver qué pasa me sean daniel tú me
sabes de arte pasó el tiempo y después
de mucho esfuerzo
gabriel se empezó a ser famoso sus obras
empezaron a cotizar en miles y miles de
dólares y yo le pregunté al maestro
maestro qué vamos a hacer con todo tu
dinero y con esa sonrisita se me quedó
bien de mi hijo y si nos traemos más
gente viene a tu departamento
obviamente elige qué no elige si no va a
caer soltero toda la vida
y gabriel viene a enseñarme dos
lecciones y muchas otras lecciones que
ni las mejores universidades del mundo
ni en casa me enseñaron y que no solo
los emprendedores sino todo ser humano
debe saber la primera sobre el dinero un
dia gabriel empezó a hacer un cuadro con
miles de billetes de un dólar y de
veinte pesos mexicanos y yo maestro que
andas haciendo y su cuadro y gabriel
todo los días regresaba y me decía
daniel es que porque la gente al ver mi
cuadro en la calle se transforma me
insultan intentan robar me critican
porque el dinero los transforma el ego
mira maestro es como estar aquí afuera y
ver a un hombre con 20 mil dólares en un
cuadro reales pues le digo nadie está
acostumbrado a eso y me dice es que la
gente no entiende que el dinero no es
dinero y yo oí que es y este cuadro se
llama el dinero no es dinero es papel lo
que ustedes ven ahí es un remolino de
dinero con un horizonte manos tratando
agarrarlo y gabriel lo que nos enseña el
mundo del dinero es que el dinero no
puede ser lo más importante el dinero no
es bueno ni malo es un medio pero el
objetivo tiene que ser superior si tú
haces lo que te apasiona y eres
habilidoso lo que hace es eventualmente
el dinero va a llegar a la vida
ahora la segunda lección muy diferente a
la del dinero es sobre la vida misma un
día yo estaba con un amigo cerca de 50
años de nombre daniela invitaba mucho a
cenar y yo le dije oye porque me invitas
tanto a cenar y un día me dices que tú
me recuerdas a mi hijo es un emprendedor
tiene 18 años es igual que tú pero acaba
de fallecer
y no hay que callar no sabía ni qué
decir empezó a llorar regresa a casa
destruido una de la mañana y gabriel
llegar a la casa está haciendo un
cuaderno con siempre y gabriel detecta
todos los sentimientos inmediatamente me
dijo qué te pasa por qué tan triste y le
cuento la historia y me dice porque no
le contestaste lo que debiste haber
contestado y yo que le dices y me dice
pues que el arte inmortaliza las
personas y yo como y me dice haber
enseñado la fotografía el niño la que te
enseñó que tenía la cartera y la enseña
esa fotografía y le estuvo viendo horas
le tuve que dar hasta la contraseña del
celular porque yo me fui a dormir no y
no se volvió a tocar el tema pasaron
seis meses y un día a gabriel llegó a mi
casa y me dice daniels
quiero que vayas con tu amigo daniel y
le digas que el dany y yo ya somos
amigos hemos estado viajando por todo el
país y efectivamente el arte inmortaliza
a las personas yo lo pueda creer lo que
ustedes ven ahí nuevamente son
kilómetros y kilómetros de hilo de
colores cuando yo le entrega esta obra a
sus padres yo ya las lágrimas salir de
sus ojos
y gabriel no sabía dejar una gran
lección efectivamente el arte
inmortaliza a las personas ahora cuando
fueron a imaginar que un día yo iba a
estar traduciendo una conversación entre
steve que el confundador de apple
y gabriel y los dos hablaban acerca de
que no creían en los humanos ni en el
dinero y yo pero puse ustedes son
humanos y tienen lana
pero bueno en fin
un día a gabriel ya conmigo mi historia
miel necesito crema
para steve wozniak y yo a ver cómo pero
necesitas un número tú me tienes celular
y mi seno es que luego me encuentran y
yo ok me dice no es que le hizo un
cuadro de él su esposa janet sus
perritos y gisele dijo que cuando
estuviera listo le escribiera y me a el
celular yo dije este hombre está loco
como batear el whatsapp de steve wozniak
le escribí y contestó
cuando te fuiste imaginar cuando gabriel
hace siete años vi en la calle ahora
esto me lleva a encontrar la palabra y
la definición de emprendimiento pero
antes de eso voy que gabriel es famoso y
conocido todo lo quieren conocer ahora
sí pero nadie sabe los sacrificios que
hay detrás de todo eso yo llegaba a mi
casa era un caos y todavía gabriel usaba
mi ropa porque según él era mejor para
el calor de monterrey
nos peleábamos por supuesto pero se
hicieron muchos sacrificios para llegar
a donde estamos el día de hoy faltan
muchos sacrificios por hacer ahora abril
y hoy viajamos por todo el mundo y les
puedo decir que gabriel es como mi
hermano cada vez que se va ahora sí que
lo extraña ahora un día llegó con estado
y le dije maestro no me digas que yo le
voy a encontrar algo
y no le encuentre nada a las suyas redes
sociales y me decían no pues les
pregunté que ven y me deseando un
pajarito o un payaso y los telas hasta
veían un mexicano cruzando la frontera
espero que ustedes hayan visto cosas
menos locas
y dije no no concuerdo con nada dije ya
sé dónde voy a colgar este cuadro en
frente de la taza del baño dije aquí a
huevo se me ocurre a los seis meses
estuvo ahí no se me ocurre nada hasta
que un día llegó gabriel a casa y
maestro estoy harto dime qué es esa obra
y me dice no es nada es un cuadro
abstracto
y yo enseño que no es nada así es el
arte abstracto y en aquel momento
metafóricamente hizo una relación entre
el arte abstracto y el emprendimiento y
me di cuenta que así como el arte
abstracto el emprendimiento no tiene
inicio no tiene final y cada quien tiene
su propia interpretación mientras muchas
busca del secreto la fórmula la receta
si tú eres trabajador te rodeas de los
mejores eres persistente haces lo que te
apasiona puedes llegar a donde quieras
no hay una receta ahora eso me inspira a
escribir mi primer libro que tiene el
título de esta conferencia lo abstracto
de emprender y porque le puse un zapato
rojo a laporta el libro porque siempre
uso para patos rojos no les quiero dejar
un mensaje el día de hoy cada vez que
ustedes vean un zapato rojo a partir del
día de hoy quiero que recuerdan que
tengan los pies bien puestos en la
tierra hay que ser humildes no hay que
olvidar de dónde venimos cómo llegamos a
donde estamos alguien nos compartió para
llegar ahí y hay que volver a la
comunidad que abrirnos vídeo enseñar
cientos direcciones pero cuántos de
ustedes nos han topado en la calle con
alguien como gabriel cuántos de ustedes
no han visto a un líder social
político-empresarial un líder en el
mundo de la gastronomía la literatura
las artes y lo han podido apoyar pero
cuánta gente durante 15 años lo paso
enfrente gabriel y ni siquiera le
preguntó su nombre ni siquiera le
ofreció un vaso de agua
para esto se necesita diálogo
la pregunta que yo les quiero hacer el
día de hoy es ustedes ya conocen al
siguiente botero colombiano y si es así
en que lo están ayudando muchas gracias
[Aplausos]